Nouvel épisode de la série Dans son corps aujourd'hui je reçois Jean, de la chaîne "Accropolis" qui vient nous parler de sa particularité à lui.
Qui n'est pas si particulière dans la mesure où elle est très répandue...
...et justement c'est bien l'intérêt d'en parler.
Jean est streameur et youtubeur, il tient la chaîne Accropolis qui parle de politique et des institutions publiques en france.
Salut Jean
Salut julien!
-Alors quelle est ta particularité à toi?
Ma particularité à moi c'est que je suis atteint d'une maladie qui s'appelle la dépression.
La dépression est une maladie fréquente, puisqu'on estime qu'en France elle touche une personne sur cinq au cours de sa vie.
A l'échelle mondiale elle touche 300 millions de personnes.
Tu peux raconter un peu ton histoire par rapport à ça?
- ouais
-Notamment le moment où tu
t'es rendu compte que t'avais un truc
Alors c'est vrai, c'est génial parce que précisément dire de la dépression que c'est une maladie c'est déjà en soi une gageure
et c'est un sujet intéressant parce que c'est une des preuves que la dépression est mal comprise
y compris par les personnes qui en sont atteintes
et donc justement pour répondre à ta question à quel moment est-ce que je ... et ben en fait je sais pas !
Je ne sais pas parce que la dépression c'est pas une maladie qui se déclenche,
c'est pas vraiment comme ça que ça marche, c'est plutôt un truc qui s'installe en temps long
et donc qui se diagnostique longtemps après et à la lumière de laquelle tu peux comprendre des choses plus tard donc moi ça fait
plusieurs années que je souffre d'un truc
sur lequel un diagnostic a été posé
assez tôt mais qui est un diagnostic que j'ai refusé pendant longtemps
et refuser un diagnostic ça veut dire que
que j'étais dans le déni, que je pensais que c'était juste des problèmes de...
D'humeur
psychique, ... des trucs passagers en fait!
Des traits de personnalité, des trucs comme ça. Et il a fallu il a fallu des années de
de travail et beaucoup de médecins pour que je finisse par accepter
l'idée que j'étais atteint d'une maladie et que ça s'appelle la dépression et que c'est particulier et que voilà !
La dépression c'est une maladie, elle a des origines diverses et elle peut se manifester de différentes façons.
Pour toi, est-ce que tu te souviens, ... tu parles d'une espèce de...
d'acceptation, une prise de conscience.Tu te souviens
d'un déclic à un moment ou un autre?
Chaque personne atteinte de dépression a une manière différente de la vivre. C'est aussi très compliqué du coup de la détecter, de la comprendre etc... ,
mais c'est comme ça.
Et moi en l'occurrence elle est très cyclique et elle fonctionne par
avec des hauts des bas
et quand il y a des bas ça ressemble beaucoup à des burn out par exemple. C'est un autre mot qu'on entend beaucoup
Et moi il y a un burn-out très violent que j'ai fait qui m'a emmené à l'hôpital
Où j'ai... où j'ai pris conscience où j'ai pris conscience effectivement ...où il ya eu un déclic.
Un autre déclic a été important, à ce moment là, au même moment et c'était d'ailleurs dans la même semaine
c'est un livre que j'ai lu qui s'appelle
"Rester en vie". C'est un bouquin qui m'a beaucoup aidé parce que ça parle de la dépression et notamment de la prévention du suicide
et c'est un livre qui m'a appris que j'avais le droit d'être aidé !
Bah! c'est con à dire...
mais j'avais besoin de me l'entendre dire à un moment pour comprendre que, ok, en fait ça va pas, en fait c'est vraiment une maladie
en fait ils ont raison de me dire que je suis malade. Et en fait allez!
Allez,  il faut y aller quoi! Donc voilà c'est ..c'est , il y a eu ce déclic-là!
Parce que refuser d'accepter qu'on est malade c'est aussi du coup se priver de la possibilité de se
soigner...
-Et ouais ! et ouais ! absolument!
et c'est un vrai problème surtout pour cette maladie là qui est ...qui a besoin d'être soignée, qui se soigne d'ailleurs et ça aussi
c'est important.
Mais l'acceptation de la maladie est une étape difficile par laquelle il faut passer pour commencer à
trouver le chemin de la sortie quoi.  Donc ouais...
-Donc, avec deux ans de recul maintenant, est-ce que tu arrives un peu à
comprendre ce qui te
bloquait dans ton...
'fin ce qui t'empêchait d'accepter le fait que tu avais cette maladie à savoir la dépression? C'était quoi?
-C'était c'était la culpabilité, beaucoup...
C'est une maladie très stigmatisante, la dépression. Déjà parce que le regard extérieur qu'on porte dessus est empreint de clichés.
En fait on confond très souvent la dépression avec un état, avec un état d'humeur.
La dépression est une maladie qui touche l'humeur. La dépression c'est pas la déprime.
C'est pas le spleen, c'est pas la mélancolie, ...
C'est pas la tristesse! C'est plus que ça! Ça en fait partie: sont des symptômes mais c'est plus que ça. C'est aussi un affaiblissement global
de
... de tes défenses immunitaires et de ton métabolisme,
c'est un ralentissement de ton rythme de vie,
du fonctionnement de ton cerveau. C'est des troubles du sommeil, c'est des troubles de l'érection, c'est des troubles digestifs,
C'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses, la dépression! Et donc cette stigmatisation
de la dépression je la ressentais pour moi même
et donc du coup elle me... et du coup elle me faisait douter. Du coup je culpabilisais parce que
parce que parce que après tout bah je suis pas sportif donc c'est peut-être un peu aussi de ma faute, parce qu'après tout je clope
j'ai une hygiène de vie assez dégueulasse. Enfin tu me diras assez commune pour les gens de notre génération! Mais c'est comme ça
et puis en plus j'ai fait des choix de vie très spécifiques; j'ai bossé dans la politique, j'ai bossé aujourd'hui sur youtube
c'est quand même des milieux dans lesquels bah c'est pas anodin quoi! Je veux dire on vit des trucs assez intenses...
et donc ... je me sentais en fait responsable ou un minimum
complice de ma situation. Donc c'est pour ça que je n'acceptais pas le
diagnostic
-et le regard des autres?
à quel moment et dans quelle mesure est-ce qu il a joué
en ce qui te concerne?
-Il a beaucoup joué. Parce que la dépression est pas une maladie pour laquelle les symptômes sont visibles
une personne qui souffre de dépression
c'est une personne qui rit. C'est une personne qui va au cinoche, c'est une personne qui boit des coups
qui est sympa, qui est sociable, qui continue à vivre normalement!!
et donc du coup ça se voit pas! C'est pas comme t'avais des plaques sur le visage ou des trucs comme ça!
Et donc du coup...
...il y avait le regard des gens dont j'ai beaucoup souffert qui était celui de la surprise
quand j'ai enfin accepté la maladie et que j'ai commencé à en parler
de gens qui ont, ...qui eux l'ont niée comme moi je la niais avant et donc ils m'ont envoyé une image de ...
"oh ca va, mais pas du tout !!! Qu'est ce que tu racontes ..."
"Toi? Dépressif? mais pas du tout! Oui, oh, ca va...Nous aussi on a des petits passages où on est
on est vides, et tout ..."
Et en fait, j'en ai pas mal souffert de ça...
Du fait de pas être...
...compris! Que non mais je te parle pas du fait que j'ai mal dormi hier soir; je te parle d'une maladie que j'ai  depuis plusieurs
années. Qui me pèse beaucoup et tout, ...
Maintenant ça va mieux, un peu mieux
Parce que j'ai appris en parler aussi différemment j'ai appris à poser les mots j'ai appris à l'affirmer etc.
Et par ailleurs j'ai aussi eu des regards
extrêmement bienveillants des gens qui m'ont tendu la main
des gens qui m'ont accompagné qui m'ont aidé et qui m'ont fait beaucoup de bien
juste en me disant "je suis là si tu as besoin"
Ca c'est une phrase géniale par exemple! J'ai jamais rappelé quelqu'un qui m'a dit "si tu as besoin appelle moi"
mais le simple fait qu'il m'ait dit cette phrase m'a toujours fait beaucoup de bien.
C'est con mais tu vois là ça aussi c'est un regard des autres qui aide vachement.
-Oui, à l'inverse ça peut être quelque chose qui t'enfonce comme ça peut être quelque chose qui te ...
-Ouais !
-...Quelque chose qui te sort...
Exactement!
-Et par rapport à ton propre regard sur toi-même il y a eu quelque chose de l'ordre de
l'estime de toi ?
...De te dire
-Complètement!
-D'accepter le diagnostic de dépression c'est...
...me déprécier ( sans mauvais jeu de mot...)
-J'aime beaucoup le jeu de mot, haha !
Oui et en même temps
dans l'autre sens c'est vrai aussi!
C'est à dire que, oui, c'est pas facile de se regarder dans la glace et de se dire "je suis atteint de dépression".
Il y a un côté...
...misérable, ... misérabiliste...
Et en même temps, à l'inverse c'est aussi de se dire "ok j'ai le courage de me regarder en face dans la glace" et de me dire "ouais mec!
t'es atteint de dépression." Et ça m'a un peu, ... ouais, ... un peu aidé
à m'affirmer,  à savoir ce qui j'étais,  à arrêter de douter
à savoir quand j'étais dans le déni,  quand je ne l'étais pas, ...
Pareil quand j'écoutais les autres: de savoir qui était dans le déni et qui ne l'était pas et donc
et vis-à-vis du regard qu'on a sur soi même c'est particulier. D'autant qu'encore une fois la dépression est une maladie qui
impacte l'humeur et l'estime de soi.
Et donc c'est très très particulier comme maladie.
-Au quotidien, pour être assez concret,
et étalé sur le temps du début à aujourd'hui où manifestement tu gères un peu mieux, ...
Les choses les plus difficiles à vivre pour toi c'est quoi?
C'est les crises d'angoisse, l'un des aspects de la dépression c'est l'anxiété, ...
...qui en est un moteur ET un symptôme, ... Très bizarre mais c'est comme ça!
Que je vis très mal, ...
Il y a aussi eu les médicaments
que pendant longtemps, dans le cadre du déni je refusais de prendre; je les prenais mal, je les refusais, enfin il y avait un truc
très violent. Et dans l'estime de soi aussi prendre des médicaments me faisait me
faisait mal quoi...
Donc ça a été ça le plus difficile.
Après c'est des troubles du sommeil
je dors énormément et je dors très mal donc c'est des insomnies
c'est des siestes au milieu de la journée parce qu'il n'y a pas le choix parce que juste je m'effondre de fatigue.
Et puis sur l'estime de soi, on en parlait tout à l'heure, le fait de pas être au niveau
professionnellement aussi ça c'est difficile à vivre parce que la dépression, je le disais tout à l'heure, ralentit
Et puis c'est... la dépression te fait perdre ce qu'on appelle le "souffle vital" et donc l'envie de faire les choses
et c'est une maladie qui touche l'apathie donc la capacité qu'on a à ressentir du plaisir à faire ce qu'on fait.
Ça dans le milieu pro, mon gars !!...
... Ça a été très compliqué à vivre. Mais heureusement j'ai été accompagné, j'ai été aidé!
Mais justement à l'inverse, ...
....avec le recul, maintenant, puisque tu es
sur un chemin de ...
-Oui, j'espère, j’espère, ...
vers la guérison
-Mais tu sais de la même manière qu'on ne peut pas dire à quel moment ça a commencé une dépression
...ça s'arrête pas un jour. Il y a un jour où je serais très très content d'affirmer avec le sourire que j'étais malade avant
ce jour là viendra mais je sais pas quand!
C'est pas forcément un objectif qu'il faut se fixer parce qu'il peut paraître inatteignable, mais que l'objectif c'est peut-être juste de se dire...
..."je suis dépressif j'ai une dépression mon objectif en tout cas comme le premier pas c'est
de continuer à vivre avec ça, d'apprendre à vivre avec ça, en progressant
jusqu'au jour où je pourrai me dire
c'est derrière moi!"
-Exactement!
Et c'est ça aussi qui est intéressant dans cette maladie c'est toute la notion justement de maladie, de guérison, de pathologie, ...
parce que j'ai aussi
beaucoup appris sur la dépression en me renseignant et en m'informant dessus et j'ai appris que c'est une maladie qui fait l'objet d'une controverse médicale
très intéressante entre des chercheurs...
qui ont des approches différentes des choses. Il y a une approche psychanalytique de la dépression mais il y a aussi de nouvelles approches
notamment du côté des neurosciences.
Tout ça est très technique, tout ça est très compliqué mais tout ça montre bien qu'en fait la dépression est une maladie mal connue
mal comprise y compris aujourd'hui par le corps scientifique qui fait des progrès et des beaux progrès! Il ya des belles choses qui sont faites
il y a des progrès sur des molécules anti dépresseurs
qui ont été faites
Donc oui, effectivement, guérir d'une dépression c'est se passer de médicaments, c'est apprendre à vivre avec, ...
apprendre à maîtriser ses angoisses etc.
Donc c'est un long travail
à mon avis multifactoriel, il n'y a pas de pilule magique ! Ca faut vraiment aussi se mettre ça dans le crâne
mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire.
Toi, concrètement,...
les trucs qui t'ont vraiment aidé à avancer, à vivre avec, dans un premier temps c'est quoi?
-Alors il ya eu...
il y a eu plusieurs choses, d'ailleurs il y a eu des vidéos sur youtube
je pense notamment à une vidéo du psy lab
où ils ont parlé de la dépression grâce à laquelle j'ai appris beaucoup de choses qui m'ont aidé à comprendre
cette maladie, il y a le livre dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure,
il y a aussi des médecins qui m'ont accompagné et des médecins de l'hôpital. Aujourd'hui je suis suivi par
par l'hôpital.
J'ai du coup découvert le monde de ce qu'on appelle la psychiatrie de cette spécialités de la médecine qui s'occupe des troubles psychiques et mentaux
Qui travaillent en équipes qui font un travail extraordinaire en lien avec l'hôpital sur les territoires
voilà je rentre pas dans le détail mais aujourd'hui je suis suivi de très près par une équipe
qui prend soin de moi et ça ça m'a considérablement aidé
Est-ce que tu as souvenir de, ...
...on est d'accord il n'y a pas de pilules magiques, il n'y a pas non plus la phrase magique,
mais peut-être un truc un jour qui t'a vraiment fait tilter, qui
potentiellement peut aider les gens qui verront cette vidéo, ...
Un conseil ou une phrase
-Ouais, ...et la phrase, ...
la phrase que j'avais besoin d'entendre et qu'en l’occurrence j'ai lu dans le livre c'est "Tu as le droit d'être malade et
t'as le droit d'être aidé"
Il a fallu qu'à un moment je l'entende, ça! Et donc ça m'a beaucoup aidé et par ailleurs
la dépression est une maladie qui, dans mon cas ne l'est pas, mais qui peut être grave
notamment puisque la dépression est très présente dans les cas de suicide et c'est extrêmement important que les personnes qui souffrent,
qui se sentent pas bien, qui peut-être dans cette vidéo et en écoutant, se reconnaissent un peu dans ce que je dis
n'hésitent pas à appeler des numéros de téléphone qui sont faits pour ça. A se présenter dans des services d'urgence,
la dépression peut avoir différentes intensités, de modérée à grave, mais peut surtout évoluer si elle n'est pas prise en charge
Selon l'OMS, chaque année 800.000 personnes meurent en se suicidant.
Je sais que ça fait peur, je me suis retrouvé moi même aux urgences psychiatriques de l'hôpital
Ca fait peur!
Dit comme ça, mais en fait j'étais au bon endroit et on
s'est occupé de moi et c'est normal c'était ma place, ici, c'était la bonne idée.
Donc se faire aider, c'est normal il faut le faire et c'est quand on en ressent le besoin il faut pas hésiter.
Vraiment, c'est important
Ce serait ton conseil, ...
-Ouais!
-Si tu devais t'adresser directement aux gens qui se sentiront concernés?
Si ça va pas bien et que vous ne vous sentez pas bien, n'hésitez pas...
...à en parler à votre médecin, y compris votre médecin généraliste c'est son boulot aussi de vous orienter
d'aller vous faire rencontrer des personnes dont c'est le boulot. Donc voilà, vous avez le droit de pas vous sentir bien c'est normal
ça fait partie des choses, mais vous avez aussi le droit d'être aidé!
-Je te remercie beaucoup!
-Merci à toi julien
Bon! Bonne suite!
-Ouais,
Bonne suite de chemin, bon courage
-Salut, mec!